[Music]
we must make sure we always mark Park
bing-bang
pay attention hi bong bing bang bong
bong excuse me and we are up we want to
play a little game with you called out
of the blue so I'm going to ask you a
series of questions that all have the
word blue in it are you ready
a career highlight that blew you away
I think being nominated for a Grammy was
the career highlight of my life probably
trying out against hundreds and hundreds
of other kids from around the world for
the Carnegie Mellon School of Drama and
then getting that letter in the mail
that said that I was accepted was
probably you know probably still to this
day like the biggest thrill what about a
time where you felt like you just blew
it in Hollywood I went through a lot of
stuff growing up and I went through some
challenges and some obstacles and I felt
like at a period of time I probably
wasn't gonna work again but as I
overcame those struggles it actually
gave me more of a I found my purpose
through metal so when it came out the
other side yes uh well the first job in
Hollywood that I was offered was this
role in spider-man I was offered by it
by Sam Raimi and two weeks later my
roommate came home and said that her
friend auditioned from the role that
they gave me and the head of the studio
didn't think I was right for the part
because I didn't look like the character
in the comic book so they took it away
and they auditioned other people for
about a month and a half and the role
wound up coming back my way because they
didn't find anyone else mmm that's right
which is how they put it uh which didn't
make me feel great but um oh but that
was that was a tough pill to swallow
about this business that we're in no
matter how successful you think you are
even if when they call you so you've got
the role until you're actually rolling
camera and then you're sitting in a
theater watching yourself up on screen
you just don't know looking out into the
blue one thing that you want to achieve
this year I hope that I'm a good mom to
my two
that's good and I also want to make an
awesome album yeah so I heard your new
song today oh thank you yes I came out
with a song today with cheat codes
called no promises it's so different but
I love it it's so fun and something yeah
any that kind of setting the tone for
what you want the album to sound like I
actually want to go a totally different
way with my album I want to go more
soulful and um so we'll see what that
ends up turning out like I'm still in
the process of writing and finding the
inspiration behind it so we'll see
[Music]
you